let's go to timothy from miami now
timothy are you in miami or miami beach
uh i am just in miami okay that's fine
that's okay that's allowed
oh sorry um
i
i'm sorry let me turn down my microphone
here um
is there a way for you to turn me down
or do i have to do it myself
no you're you're everything's fine what
was on your mind today
oh well uh i just want to say i wanted
to bring up a good point that hopefully
you could tell to other people sure
but uh the thing is so i i've noticed
that
the republicans and the whole idea of
the trump
of trump
winning the 2020 election and writing
the lie that he did the big lie uh it's
kind of like our modern day version of
the lost cosmetics from the civil war do
you understand what i mean no not at all
well it's the sense that conservatives
are once again lying about something you
know with the lost cause narrative is
the idea that the civil war was not
about slavery it was about states rights
you know what i mean it all revolves
around a lie where today it's donald
trump didn't lose the 2020 election joe
biden stole it you understand what i
mean in that sense you know i kind of do
yeah the the lost cause of the
confederacy is the general narrative
that really the motivation for um the
confederacy was to preserve states
rights in principle and it just so
happened that that would also allow
slavery to remain legal but that really
wasn't what they wanted it wasn't about
slavery i just don't know that i'm
understanding how that is equivalent to
the big lie you're just saying it was a
lie that that's what the confederacy was
about and it's a lie that trump won both
are just lies
i mean i guess it's also that
it and that and also in the fact that
it's also being peddled by once again
these extremist conservatives that you
know have not really gone away and you
know
it it it just seems there's just
something about both situations that
seem because you know a lot of time in
american politics a lot of the
situations that we're suffering from
today are often the same issues are
often rehashed issues
from generations ago you know oh well so
i don't know if this is exactly what you
mean and i apologize if we're having
trouble understanding each other but one
of the things that that you're saying
that is actually resonating a lot is
we're talking now so long after the
civil war and yet you still hear certain
political partisans repeat this thing it
wasn't about slavery for us it wasn't
about slavery for the confederacy
could the big lie become that we're even
a hundred years from now you still
continue to have people saying you know
trump really did win in 2020. that you
know that seems possible
i was going to say that you know
southern you know southern people have
you know engraved this into the minds of
their children and to their
grandchildren and i believe it's very
possible they also could have tried to
change southern history you know
propaganda film stuff like that you got
death of a nation yeah it's very
possible these extreme trumpet
conservatives that are somehow even more
extreme will uh try to do something to
put into people's minds that uh trump
really did not uh lose and if 2024
does not go for trump uh we could be
seeing some
catastrophic violations of history
freedom of speech do you understand what
i mean i do very much so i do very much
so
it's kind of like the same effect and
i'm it's just something
about it that i just can't get out of my
head
well you've said it beautifully and i
share your concern and let's monitor and
see what happens
thank you so much david i'm a huge fan
of the show last time i was later call
it didn't really go well it was during
uh buying state of the union address
okay well i'm glad we were able to
communicate today there's timothy from
miami and on that note we're going to go
to a break we will take calls again soon
and when we do
i hope to be able to speak to you